"Hey!"
I
Didn't think we could make another episode
But
We did it
A lot of these are thanks to you guys
Number 1
So we know that you can shortcut to your first item quickslot by holding down on the D-Pad
But did you know
That you can also shortcut to your first attune spell
by holding up?
Pure spell caster builds
have always had it tough
with toggling between spells.
And the highest skill cap thing
you can do as a caster, really
is quickly switch between spells
to confuse your opponents.
So this gives you more control.
Does this make sorcery viable in PVP?
No, no it doesn't.
Nothing will.
Number two is in the running
for the most obscure secret of Dark Souls 3.
So summon an NPC phantom
called Swamp Cuculus
outside of the Old Demon king
boss fog. And then kill
the Old Demon King with Cuculus still alive.
Then have an epiphany about
how Cuculus is obviously
Cornyx's apprentice
And remember to check back att Cornyx's cage in the undead settlement
A corpse will now be there, holding Cornyx's amazing pyromancy set
And the spotted whip which poisons foes
If you found this naturally in your playthrough, well done.
This isn't all you can get from summoning NPC's though.
If Knightslayer Tsorig kills you and be honest, I mean he killed everyone right?
You get the "My thanks!" emote.
If you summon the Londor Pale Shade, you get the "Duel bow",
if you summon Black Hand Gothard, you get "By my sword",
and Yellowfinger gives you the "Proper bow".
I'm quite sure that there's others that I'm missing
and maybe even some that no one has discovered yet.
I don't know, if you find any let everyone know.
Number 3,
New Game Plus is disappointing
in this game.
Enemy damage doesn't seem to scale too much, and
I personally haven't noticed any
new enemy placements,
which at least Dark Souls II did right.
At any rate,
New Game Plus One and New Game Plus Two
grant access to some of the Plus One and Plus Two, and
Plus Three rings.
Some of the best ones are
the Plus Two Gold Serpent Ring,
or the Plus Two Ring of Favour.
I'll leave a list of them all in the description
if you want to hunt them down.
Number four,
so,
in the last episode,
I was really surprised to hear
that so many of you stuck in a Hollowing state
without a way to cure it.
I just realised that
it sounds like I'm making fun of you,
but it really is really hard
to cure Hollowing if you don't know how.
So,
if you don't have access to purging stones
because Yuria has gone,
then just go to the Statue of Velka,
after purchasing the Grave Key
and you can request
dissolution there.
Once you've done this and
healed the Dark Sigil at the Firekeeper,
then,
you know,
all those hours spent in the character creator,
they were no longer for nothing.
Number five,
the Hollow Gem Infusion allows a weapon to scale with your Luck stat,
which I'm discovering is
awesome if you run a Poison or Bleed build,
since those things scale with luck as well
In addition, though,
did you know actually that actually being Hollow
while also having a Hollow Infusion
gives you a plus five bonus to your Luck stat?
So, if you're running a Luck build,
just infuse your shield with Hollowing, and
even if it's on your back,
you're still reaping the benefits.
It's a neat little mechanic to make Luck that
tiny bit more viable.
Speaking of infusions,
the Simple Infusion also has a hidden benefit.
It scales with Intelligence,
but it also restores focus
At a rate of about one Focus point
per four seconds.
Now, that sounds horrible,
but
it is actually amazing for some weapons
that can take advantage of it
Take the Sunlight Straight Sword, for example.
If I have zero focus points,
then I can't cast the buff,
but if I have even one Focus point,
then I can
So, if you're using a weapon
that benefits greatly from
even a tiny amount of Focus, and
most do,
then
throw this infusion on an off-hand shield
or something, it's amazing.
Number seven is to do with consuming Souls.
If you have a ton that you want to consume,
then the fastest way
is just to sell them at the Handmaiden.
She gives you the same amount that you'd usually get.
Number eight,
when you're deciding whether to make that risky jump
because there's a shiny over there;
consider this,
important items like Estus Shards
or weapons or rings,
they have a large glow,
whereas regular items, like
consumables have a small glow.
So, if you have to choose between two items,
and a giant is about to smack the shit out of you,
then
make sure you choose the right one.
Number nine,
segway.
So, if you're like me right now
and you have a huge pile of souls to get back to, then
never fear
because here's a mechanic
I only learned about recently,
the Ring of Sacrifice makes it so that
that you don't lose Souls upon death,
which everybody knows,
but did you also know
that it gives you another chance to recover any lost Souls
already waiting for you in the world?
So, here,
you can see my Souls over there.
I'm going to recover them,
but I die on my way,
but
since I have the Ring of Sacrifice equipped,
the pile of Souls remains,
and I have another chance to recover them.
So, props to Supermandrew Seven
for making me aware of this one.
Number ten,
the Giant Tree by your shrine
it sometimes leaves a Seed of a Giant Tree behind,
which can be used used to temporarily seed your world.
Any invader into a seeded world,
will not only have to deal with the host,
they also have to deal with the normal enemies in that world,
which just, you know, pushes the odds
more into the host's favor.
I really don't get what From has against invaders.
Anyway,
the trigger for the Seed to drop
appears to be really similar to what it was in Dark Souls II,
where simply being invaded
can give you a chance to receive a Seed.
For me, I found it was about a fifty percent chance
that the seed would appear
after I was invaded,
but
my sample size was pretty small,
so it's hard to say the exact percent.
In Dark Souls II, it was twenty-five percent I believe.
Regardless,
if you do get invdaded,
then remember to check for a Seed
because you an hold up to five at a time
but only one can be at the tree
at any one time.
Number eleven,
if you want to be invaded more often,
and who doesn't?
Use a Dried Finger from the Handmaiden
Using it resets your invasion timer,
which is nothing new,
but what is new
is that it allows you to summon
a third friendly phantom
and a second
invading phantom
A hidden things is that to remove this effect,
you have to travel to a new bonfire,
not just rest at one.
When you get grabbed by the Rock Stray Demon,
did you know that you can mash the shoulder buttons
and the face buttons
to escape its grab?
Of course you did, you're a Souls veteran
and you probably do mash a lot of buttons out of reflex,
but in this game,
the only grab attack I've managed to escape from
is this one.
Mashing is no use against Mimics,
the Groos,
other bosses seem to have a set animation.
I guess the rule is that
if there's an enemy that sort of
crushes you and you can see your character
wriggle in response to your button presses, then
that is when you mash the buttons.
Thirteen,
the messaging system no longer requires an Orange Soapstone,
and it's available here in your options menu,
and at first glance, the messaging system looks terrible
but that's only until you press the triangle button,
and
all of a sudden,
you'll have access to conjugations,
another extension of your message, and
even gestures as well,
which returns from Bloodborne.
Perfect.
If a player rates that message,
positive or negative,
I'll receive a health boost,
at that moment,
but it is easy funny that it rewards you for
placing a terrible or evil message as well.
Number fourteen is a returning mechanic from Dark Souls I
It's that there's an easy way to deal with Mimics, and
there are a shitload of Mimics in this game.
Of course, you all know
that you can tell if it's a Mimic
if the chain on the side is straight, and
if the chest itself is very lightly breathing.
Just like in Dark Souls I as well, though
Lloyd's Talismans put Mimics to sleep
While asleep,
they'll allow you to pick up the item it usually drops,
so you can continue on your way after that.
If you're lucky, though,
it'll drop the Symbol of Avarice,
which is a helmet that helps you get
more item discovery
which is great in this game.
The best way to farm this
is actually just to peg* Lloyd's Talisman at it
until it drops it.
Throw a Talisman,
hit the Mimic to wake it up,
and then throw another Talisman
until you get it
or until you run out of Lloyd's Talismans
You get more Lloyd's Talismans
from the Handmaiden
after picking up
the Paladin's ashes.
Kudos to Pitara* on Reddit
for reminding me that
Lloyd's Talismans are a thing.
Alright, so this last thing
isn't just a discovery, it's
also a bit of a call to action,
which I haven't done very often,
so I'm interested to see how well this can work.
So
I can't quite figure out this mechanic.
As you played through Dark Souls III,
I'm sure you noticed that you randomly get
an extra Estus sometimes, when you kill an enemy, right?
Sometimes you even get two flasks,
myself and Illusory* Wall who is a Dark Souls wizard,
we set out to figure out exactly
what triggers this
to happen sometimes
and
so far, all we've discovered
is that certain enemies have a higher chance
to give you flasks than others,
enemies, like Dark Wraiths, for example,
they always give you two
and Red Eye Skeletons, ecetera.
The odd thing is, though,
even these enemies stopped giving us flasks after a little while.
And a similar mechanic
in Dark Souls I
with Humanity.
Enemies had a hidden point system
associated with them,
which upon death would count towards you eventually
receiving a Humanity, guaranteed.
And I have a theory
that Dark Souls III does work similar to this,
but I also have a faint hope
that the chance of you getting Estus
could be associated with the Luck stat.
I think that would be really cool,
but that's
just  because I want Luck to be accepted as a worthy stat.
So, if you want to help us figure out this mechanic,
then get out there,  drain* an Estus Flask and
record what types of enemies you have to kill
before you received a Flask.
My hope is that, with a bit more
raw data in the comments section,
then we might get a little bit closer
'cause the only thing that's confusing
is that it's irregular
after a certain point.
And if you do this,
then make sure you throw your Luck stat in the comments as well.
Maybe this is a thing.
Thanks for watching guys, um...
I know
this isn't the most interesting video I could've done.
Now there are so many amazing videos I want to make,
and the thing is I've actually commissioned
those pieces of art upon
the game coming out
and the art is still coming in,
and it just so happened this was the first video
that had its art ready,
and if you don't know
I spend like hundreds of dollars every single video
just on the art itself,
which is available for Patreons as well,
if you wanna get that as a wallpaper,
and that's just a way of rewarding people
for being able to fund
like the incredible artwork that I Iove to commission,
which I'm incredibly grateful for
Um...
Didn't mean to go on a tangent about
Paetrons and such, but
yeah, thanks for watching
regardless, and
I will see you in the next one and the next one is going to be
a very good video.
Bye guys :)